some oil flavors too like never and then
you taste it in your life maybe always I
[Music]
love hot cheetos I'm like one of those
people that just licks the hot cheetos
dust off my hand like it's like that use
it as like a fem yeah I just knew like
everything they're like a wonderful like
snack when you're hungry when you're
just like craving something to munch on
when you're high when I've just always
loved them even though they do my body
wrong I'm talking about the poops you
see this Wow it's exactly what I thought
it was was exactly what you thought it
was my mind I think hot cheeto Pegasus
oh it's kind of like a nice little
gradient inside so nuts
I have ghost pepper for one bite and
then I have Rance Cool Ranch on the
other if you love spices I would eat
this eat this and dip this in the ghost
pepper I definitely taste more offensive
more crunch what's a cheeto without
crunch I prefer the bagel it's cool man
cuz those peppers hot oh man that's the
one that you feel in your sinuses hmm oh
good
sweating on my forehead now for me yeah
hot cheetos what did it hot cheeto bagel
he's a private who did it came through
if I saw like a big like this on
mainstream patent line I would double
tap it because it does look pretty cute
I'm glad I could check this off of my
hot cheeto bucket list I didn't want to
have sex with that cheetah man I think
probably also why does he never take off
his sunglasses I don't trust exactly
where eyes it's just